ich bin sauer
ich sag's wie es ist ich bin einfach
sauer apple hat ein neues iphone update
rausgebracht und dabei ging es nicht nur
um fehler verbesserungen und neue
hintergründe oder irgendwie so nicht
es gibt auch neue images das reicht
wirklich dann auch mit applaus warum so
wenig applaus dafür fragt ihr euch jetzt
vielleicht ne ich hab mir das update
natürlich direkt aufs handy geballert
und mit dieser neuen mode diesmal
angeschaut und es war noch immer kein
hacker dabei
alle alle leute wollen eine party modi
und was bringt apple raus einen stein
und dann habe ich mir gedacht komm jetzt
okay es gibt das iphone seit zwölf
generationen wenn denen bei apple jetzt
einfällt helfrich bräuchte man steine
für alle leute die gern im stein dem
ozean verschicken dann ballert das ding
da gern reines mir scheißegal apple oder
durch weiter geschaut was noch dazu ein
herrscher kreuz
das iphone seit wann gibt es das iphone
29 der juni 2007 oder denke ich mir
es gibt die köpfe seit 13 jahren
und es gab bisher weder einen stein noch
ein holz immer ok hab ich mir gedacht
das ist nicht weiter schlimm es wird
sicherlich noch andere images geben ob
die die welt nur so gewartet hat eine
zahnbürste eine zahnbürste anscheinend
auch noch nicht und dann habe ich aber
trotzdem weiter geschaut und mit einer
wirklich mal ein bisschen ernster
reingegangen und habe mir gedacht ja
luca also da sind wirklich im dienst
sind dabei die habe ich wirklich über
jahre vermisst da denke ich mir jeden
tag ich auch beim schreiben die braucht
man einfach beispielsweise der ausguss
reiniger pümpel
oder auch dass ich weiß nicht mal wie
das ding ruhig dann allerdings diesen
komischen vogel entdeckt habe dachte ich
mir hey was gibt es sonst noch so für
neue tiere ein mammut wisst ihr seid
dann das mammut ausgestorben ist seit
13.000 jahren bei 10.000 jahre
wisst ihr seid wanders einpacker
ausgestorben ist richtig es lebt noch
wisst ihr dass das mammut gebraucht
hatte einen helm und der ist wirklich
gut es ist gut dass es diese nähe gibt
aber warum ein regenwurm bruder wird
verschickt regen wenn man das ekelhaft
genug aufgeregt meine lieben freunde
denn es kamen auch einige gute moody's
dazu wie beispielsweise der hier glaube
ich mir wirklich schon seit jahren
gewünscht und zwar ist es dann richtig
anblick von wegen du sagst dass du sie
liebst und sie antwortet einfach nur ich
lieb dich als freund und diese hand ist
auch mega begann als ich habe keine
ahnung was die genau heißen soll auf
italienisch aber ich glaube so aber an
die presse plant doch mal schnell einmal
schneller oder so halt in die richtung
ja was soll da was ich auch richtig
romantisch wie mogis immer finde ist
dass es das herz in ganz vielen
verschiedenen ausführungen gibt das gibt
es ja in den orangen grünen blau weiß
schwarz ganz normal in rot und jetzt
gibt es das herz auch wirklich als herz
und das ist das schönste was ich hier
gesehen habe
lasst dem video mal kein like da sondern
kommentiert einfach das herz
es ist wundervoll dann kam auch noch ein
demo dazu der auf sandras handy
eigentlich eher schwarz sein müsste und
zwar die lunge du kleiner sohn und
welchem motiv auch richtig richtig geil
finde ist einfach eine klassische
umarmung dass das kombiniert am besten
mit dem hier die umarmung und dass ich
jetzt auch extrem krass findet dass
justin bieber einfach einen eigenen
energiehaushalt bei den neuen tieren
muss man allerdings wirklich sagen dass
der panda und vor allem die sehr einfach
unfassbar knuffig aussehen dann kamen
allerdings natürlich auch neue insekten
dazu nämlich dass hier und der hier die
hier und ich denke einfach nur so wer
nutzt insekten images
es gibt ein paar teams die die nutzt man
einfach nicht
da weiß ich nicht wahr dass die gibt die
könntest du mir zeigen und ich würde
denken diese mit dem update dazu
gekommen aber die gibt es dann wohl seit
zehn jahren oder so zum beispiel der
hier habt ihr sie schon mal benutzt
kommentiert man eine idee noch nie
benutzt hat leider sowie mehr
interessieren beim neuen update würde
ich auf jeden fall auch niemals diese
nemo die benutzten
ich finde oliven so abartig ekelhaft
allerdings werde ich auf jeden fall
relativ häufig diese liebe nutzen es
gibt endlich eine vertrackte teekanne
und bubble tea
bild hier hatte auch mal so eine phase
ii hielt dann irgendwie nur so drei tage
und in der zeit hat sich hier diese
ungesunde scheiße rein geballert dann
kam auch noch neue modi mit dazu den ich
für uns für die luchse extrem passend
finde um unser niveau vielleicht endlich
mal zu finden nämlich eine leiter
unten spiegel
damit wir uns anschauen können
wie geil wäre es wenn dieser wenn dieser
spiegel immer einfach interaktiv wer und
immer wenn man den schickt macht er
quasi in den spiegel rein sondern foto
von einer front cam
steve jobs
apple will braucht da noch was kommt
präsentation vorbereitet was ich alles
kann was sich mitbringen stärken
schwächen habe ich keine
doch ich bin sehr perfektionistisch
deswegen brauche ich manchmal bist oder
länger wollt ihr zähne dass man kurz
überlegen
hmm
normal gerechnet nein ich zeigte sich
trotzdem damit ihr seht was er in seinen
schädel was statistisch
ich weiß ich kann wirklich mal ganz gut
gegen die migräne werfen gibt jetzt halt
auch deine schnauze luca das ist auf
jeden fall auch ein neuer mozart gewesen
dieses schild er wohl einfach nichts
drauf steht lasst uns ein bild machen wo
aber nichts draus steht für beste idee
aller zeiten und dann wurde auch noch
das hier hinzugefügt das ist einfach
eine mausefalle so und was das ist
dass das kann ich wirklich leider nicht
beantworten was das hier ist weiß ich
auch nicht so ganz
weil wer ist seine suppe mit zwei
löffeln oder ist das rahmen nicht weiß
es nicht und natürlich immer da darf
natürlich auch nicht fehlen für nachdem
man sich ein neues lokal video angeguckt
hat
ja das waren die meisten der neuen
iphone images wenn euch meine review
darauf gefallen hat dann kommentiert
gern dieses ultra romantische herz apple
realtech ich verstehe nicht warum das
sagt ackerl ich dabei ist ich habe es
doch letztes jahr schon gesagt man hat
mir doch mal richtig zu welchen die
moschee habt ihr noch nie benutzt man
lieben freunde schreibt begehrt und in
die kommentare und wenn du noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal sei dann lasst
es am besten auch
[Musik]